The upshot of bundling the IPC and recovery management is that a service
can safely collect all the breadcrumbs it left behind in all the places that it
touched through the course of its service.
Examples of such breadcrumbs include memory that
was allocated but not reclaimed, file handles,
communication handles, or often windows that have
been created on the display. All of these
are breadcrumbs that may be left behind by
failed clients or servers. And the fact that
you have a transaction tree that records the
trail of all the nodes that were touched
and the temporary states that were created in
all these nodes allows these breadcrumbs to be
cleanly reclaimed. And there is no extra communication for
the recovery management itself, because whatever
communication is needed for the transaction managers
to talk to one another in participating in the transaction that is shadowing the
IPC, actually rides on the IPC itself, and therefore it comes for free.
And Quicksilver only provides the mechanisms. The
policy is entirely up to each service.
And in fact, services can simply ignore these
mechanisms if they don't need any recovery management,
or choose a policy that is commensurate with
the type of service that it is providing.
Because there's a variety of mechanisms available in
the operating system, simple services may choose to
use low-overhead mechanisms. Whereas a more involved service
such as a file server may use weighty mechanisms
in order to recover from failures. The
overhead for recovery management in Quicksilver is
very similar to what we already saw
in LRVM. The transaction managers have to write
log records at every one of these
nodes. Because they are handling the interactions
between clients or servers at this node
with respect to other sites, the transaction managers
have to write log records for
recovering persistent state. Similar to LRVM, Quicksilver
also uses in-memory logs for the
transaction managers. And these transaction managers flush
the in-memory logs that they create
to record persistent states to disk periodically.
How often these in-memory log records are written out to the disk by
the transaction manager is a performance factor,
and it is a window of vulnerability just
as in LRVM. Ideally, if you want to be absolutely sure that you can recover from
failures, whenever any persistent state is modified and
a log record is written by the transaction
manager, that log record should be committed to
the storage. But that costs synchronous I/O, and
so if you're worried about that, you might want to do
that more opportunistically, assuming there are not going to be too
many failures. So there is a performance vulnerability trade off in
how often the transaction manager writes log records to the storage device.